we're going to be broadcasting a week of  shows from comic-con in San Diego whole  week it all starts Wednesday July 8  that's right Wednesday July 8 here to  tell us more is a brand new character we  just invented please welcome The Singing  comic book let's get him out here  I'm the singing comic book and I'm in  mint condition I'm the very first  printing of a limited edition I've got a  cardboard back and a plastic sleeve and  I've got to sing it at diddy right now  before I leave guys are there air holes  in this hole Brian see how they took  Kavitha it's seriously very difficult to  breathe I can't I'm losing I don't know  who design that's been anyway he's dead  the point is were coming to Comic Con  Wednesday July 18th through Saturday the  11th  be there because he's dead wasn't that a  great clip subscribe to my youtube  channel for an endless supply of me  [Laughter]